BREAK.
IN I'M TRACE GALLAGHER.
NOW BACK TO SEAN HANNITY.
♪
>> Sean: WELCOME BACK WITH
THIS SPECIAL EDITION OF
HANNITY.
JOINING US NOW TO REACT TO
THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH AT
CPAC THE HOST OF THE HIT JOE
JUSTICE JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO
IS WITH US.
SHE IS AT CPAC 2018.
ALL RIGHT, JUDGE, SO YOU GOT
TO SPEAK AFTER THE PRESIDENT
TONIGHT.
BUT TO THE BIG DINNER WHICH
WE'RE SO PROUD OF YOU, AND,
LOOK, YOU WERE THERE, YOU
SAW THE SPEECH.
THE FACT THAT GALLUP IS EVEN
SAYING THAT OPTIMISM HAS
CHANGED.
RASMUSSEN NOW HAS THEM AT A
MAGIC NUMBER OF APPROVAL
50%.
RESULTS MATTER TO PEOPLE.
AND I THINK RESULTS MATTER
MORE THAN NOISE THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM THE LAST YEAR.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S AMAZING
IS THE ENERGY IN THE ROOM
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SPOKE WAS
VERY UPLIFTING.
IT WAS OPTIMISTIC.
AND IT REFLECTS THE FACT
THAT PROBABLY IN AS LONG AS
I CAN REMEMBER, WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT WHO ACTUALLY
FULFILLED THE PROMISES HE
MADE DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
THE PRESIDENT WAS FIRM.
HE WAS FUNNY.
HE WAS PERSONAL.
AND HE WAS RESOLUTE.
RESOLUTE IN MAKING SURE THAT
AMERICAN CONFIDENCE IS UP.
THAT UNDER EMPLOYMENT,
UNEMPLOYMENT IS DOWN.
AND THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO MAKE A LIVING.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
SECURE AND SAFE CITIES.
HE HIT ALL THE NOTES.
HE HIT IT OUT OF THE PARK.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU,
PAUL SPERRY HAD A GREAT
PIECE OUT TODAY.
A SMART WRITER IN THE "NEW
YORK POST."
IS HE TALKING ABOUT DEVIN
NUNES AND THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE AND THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENT.
AND WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING AT
IS THE ICA, INCLUDING THEIR
FOOTNOTES TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANY ANALYSIS.
IN OTHER WORDS, WAS THAT
LIKE THE FISA PRECOOKED ON
THE UNVERIFIED DOSSIER?
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU HAVE THE
FBI, THE NSA, THE CIA, WERE
THEY USING AN UNVERIFIED
DOSSIER IN YOU THIS
CAPACITY?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THERE
IS ANY QUESTION THAT THEY
WERE.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
QUESTION THAT THEY KNEW,
THAT THEY PAID FOR IT THAT
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
WERE INVOLVED IN IT.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENED WAS
THEY DID EVERYTHING THEY
COULD TO SPREAD IT AMONG THE
MEDIA AND TO USE IT IN A
COURT.
ONE OF THE MOST -- THE
HIGHEST, ONE OF THE MOST
PRIVATE COURTS IN THE
COUNTRY IN A FISA COURT.
>> Sean: IF THE INTEL
COMMUNITY ITSELF WAS USING
THE UNVERIFIED DOSSIER FOR
THEIR ISA, THAT'S WHAT I'M
ASKING.
DID THEY USE IT FOR FISA AND
FOR THEIR OWN INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING?
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY'RE
BELIEVING IN THEIR OWN LIE?
>> OF COURSE THEY ARE
BELIEVING THEIR OWN LIE.
BECAUSE IF THEY DIDN'T
BELIEVE THEIR OWN LIE, SEAN,
THEN THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO PERPETUATE THE NARRATIVE
THAT THEY ARE PERPETUATING.
SEAN, WE ARE AT A POINT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY WHERE IF WE
DON'T MAKE THAT SHARP TURN,
THEN WE'RE, YOU KNOW, HEADED
FOR THE TOMBS AT THIS POINT.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ELECTED
DONALD TRUMP.
BECAUSE THE NARRATIVE AND
THE LIES AND THE PLAYBOOK
HAS BEEN UNBELIEVABLE.
I'M SORRY TO SAY THIS, LOOK,
I GAVE 30 YEARS OF MY LIFE
IN GOVERNMENT.
I WAS A BELIEVER.
AND I AM STUNNED AT THE LIES
AND AT THE CRIMINALITY, THE
CORRUPTION AND CONSPIRACY.
>> Sean: I NEVER THOUGHT I
COULD SEE THIS IN OUR
LIFETIME.
ESPECIALLY GOING TO A FISA
JUDGE.
I HAVE TWO JUDGE QUESTIONS.
ONE IS ON THE ISSUE OF NOT
TELL THE FISA COURT JUDGE.
JUST A FOOTNOTE MAY BE
POLITICAL IN NATURE WHEN
THEY KNEW IT WAS HILLARY
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR.
AND WHAT DO YOU MAKE ABOUT
THE JUDGE THAT ALSO WAS THE
JUDGE IN THE SENATOR TED
STEPHENS CASE IN ALASKA?
HE IS NOW GENERAL FLYNN'S
JUDGE.
AND THIS JUDGE WANTS ALL
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE AND HE
WILL DECIDE WHAT'S
EXCULPATORY IN THE FLYNN
CASE TO BE SENT TO HIM.
THAT SEEMS TO BE HIGHLY
UNUSUAL.
>> LOOK, SEAN, I SAID IT
FROM THE GET-GO.
THE IDEA OF A FISA COURT ON
THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
AND THERE IS SOMETHING
CALLED FORUM SHOPPING.
THAT MEANS AND WHEN I WAS A
JUDGE WE USED TO SAY WE HAVE
A WHEEL.
YOUR NAME JUST COMES UP WHEN
IT COMES UP.
NONSENSE.
ALL RIGHT.
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE GOT
TED STEPHENS JUDGE WHO IS
THE SAME ONE SIGNING THE
FISA -- THE 90 DAY
EXTENSIONS BASED ON NOTHING
OTHER THAN THAT DOSSIER, AND
UNTIL AND UNLESS YOU GIVE ME
MORE EVIDENCE, I'M GOING TO
SAY IT'S BASED ON NOTHING
BUT A FAKE DOSSIER, THEN
WHAT WE HAVE GOT IS A
PROBLEM IN THE JUDICIARY.
I WOULD HAVE EXPECTED A FISA
JUDGE TO SAY EVERYBODY, CUT
IT RIGHT HERE.
COURTS FOR YOUR POLITICAL
AGENDA UNHEARD OF.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT FLYNN.
>> THEY ARE AS CORRUPT AS
THE PROSECUTOR.
>> Sean: IS THIS JUDGE
LOOKING TO MAYBE THROW THIS
PLEA DEAL OUT THAT FLYNN
MADE?
>> THE IDEA THIS JUDGE WILL
DECIDE WHAT IS EXCULPATORY
AND WHAT IS GOING TO ADMIT
AND NOT ADMIT IS A
CONTINUATION OF THEIR
NARRATIVE.
I WOULDN'T TRUST THEM.
WHAT I WOULD DO TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU AND GENERALLY I
TRUST ALL JUDGES.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE GOT A
CONFLICT.
YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
RECUSE YOURSELF.
HAVE YOU AN OBLIGATION TO
SAY, LOOK, I HAVE GOT A
PROBLEM HERE.
LET ME GIVE IT TO ANOTHER
JUDGE.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT HE IS OR
ISN'T BAD.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHEN IT SMELLS OR WHEN THERE